[Música]
gostaria de agradecer com muita honra o
convite para participar do 3º tex da
uftm 2019
este é mais um desafio na minha vida vou
contar uma história para vocês o que
você pretende para a sua vida
nascido em uberaba aos seis anos de
idade
minha mãe percebeu que o meu olho
esquerdo era mais um aí ela tampouco me
perguntou quantos dedos têm aqui eu
disse pois aí tampouco direito e
pergunto aqui quantos desistem
eu não sei eu não estou enxergando ela
muito emocionada percebeu e eu também
que não enxergava do esquerdo
depois disso levou o paulista que ficou
com óculos para o direito porque eu
tinha meu pia e eu olho esquerdo
eu tinha uma catarata e ao longo do
tempo eu fui passando por um tratamento
e aos 11 anos de idade foi operado na
catarata no olho esquerdo
um mês depois da cirurgia eu fui e
voltei para a escola e foi brincar de
bola o astro o ala o mastro é o mastro
fincados no chão com uma corda e
amarrado numa bola
aí um colega de aula
brincando do lado direito de um morro na
bola que pegou no meu olho esquerdo que
usava óculos e os estilhaços planetário
no olho
criando hemorragia e essa hemorragia fez
com que 11 uma prótese com esta
hemorragia
o problema foi seguindo para o direito e
esse oftalmologista índico que fizesse
exames de toxoplasmose em são paulo e lá
foi constatado a doença e ela
gradativamente fez com que eu perdesse a
visão do olho direito e eu fui perceber
que aos 12 para 13 anos estava
completamente cego aí ocorreu um
fenômeno
os meus olhos o direito
eu vejo a fumaça colorida como arco íris
com todas as cores
vocês sabem a soma de todas as cores
formou branco ea ausência das cores mas
seu preto não é o meu caso mas acatada
som que eu escuto eu percebo uma cor
como a voz da minha filha tem uma cor
azulada a da minha mãe tem um amarelo
dourado e depois que ocorreu tudo isso
eu fui
ter braille a linguagem dos séculos
através de seis pontos
a escrita e leitura em alto relevo
deixei a escola onde estudava para fazer
esse curso de braille ii nas horas vagas
eu escutava música
escutávamos rádios tv e me veio a idéia
de gravar fitas cassetes existir na
época buscava música em são paulo e
fazer uma seleção exclusiva de buscas
que não tocar em rádio tocava nas
discotecas
percebendo que havia uma demanda no
mercado
fiz um investimento comprou equipamento
a fazer festinhas na época chamada de
brincadeira
passei a fazer aniversários casamentos e
tocava nas boates e casas noturnas
e aí eu retornei ao colégio para estudar
uma irmã alcançou e foi estudar junto
comigo foi minha colega de aula e como
não existir livros não existia o
apostilas nada apropriado para os
deficientes e estudam em uma escola
normal
eu sentava na carteira bem à frente para
escutar com os professores davam de
lição na sala de aula
e para fazer as provas eu te tava a as
matérias eram aplicadas por alguém da
diretoria e isso foi a forma com que eu
me adaptei para estudar pra completar o
ensino fundamental e médio
aí um tio meu que morava no rio de
janeiro me convidou pra que eu fosse lá
conversar com uma deficiente visual
ela tinha muito a me orientar fui pro
rio aí ela me disse e não gostou que
existiam muitos recursos para que os
cegos descem ter independência era o que
eu queria
ela me chamou vamos para são paulo um
congresso e vai ter lá eu topei na hora
aí fomos pra assistir a primeira
assembléia internacional para o
bem-estar social dos cegos e lá um deles
mudou completamente minha vida
ele foi palestrará sobre informática
sobre computadores do que existe de mais
avançado nos anos 70 ele palestrou sou
com um computador cujo teclado adaptado
no computador e ao lado tinha uma
impressora braille para cegos lerem o
que se digita
agora ele a lei entrou durante duas
horas e foi aplaudido depois dez minutos
de pé
pasmem ele era seguro e surdo só falava
mas como é que se publicava com ele
é interessante ela pelo tato se cutucava
no braço como o código morse era a forma
que se passava as informações para ele e
foi aí
o que eu percebi que não existia
barreiras para aqueles que querem vencer
os obstáculos a vencer os medos e
superar um problema
o dele era muito maior do que o meu
e a partir disso me deu muita motivação
para enfrentar a vida aí nesse mesmo
congresso
eu visitei uma estande de uma entidade
de são paulo que na época era fundação
para o livro do cego no brasil hoje
conhecido como fundação dorina de gouvêa
essa instituição trazia mais
independência
uma vida que eu queria é ser mais
independente
aí fiz minha inscrição pra poder fazer
esse curso
minha vontade era tanta que tudo que eu
fiz nos exames
eu passei foi aprovado e chamado no ano
seguinte que foi 1975 e para lá eu fui
sozinho e lá eu fui aprender as
atividades da vida diária e também
aprendi que nós é que temos que nos
adaptar ao meio e não meio que tem que
se adaptar a gente
cabe a nós orientamos as pessoas a
limitação a situação que cada um tem o
que faz é demonstrando aquilo que sabe
fazer
eu fui desenvolver os três sentidos
o tato a audição e olfato e fui aprender
a me locomover
com essa bengala e ela que é uma
extensão do tato
com isso que eu aprendi as texturas se
um tapete metal pedra árvore grama todas
as texturas através da extensão do tato
aí eu aprendi a caminhar ea bengala
emite som ao bater no chão ela emite um
som como radar
isso facilitou a minha independência
depois eu fui aprender a aperfeiçoar a
audição
você passa a ter mais concentração do
que ouve
aí eu aprendi 360 graus de onde vêm os
sons de onde vêm as vozes distância e
associado a um sentido do olfato
eu tô passando numa rua sinto cheiro de
remédio é uma farmácia
siga em frente tito cheiro de pão em uma
padaria e um pouco mais adiante cheiro
de gasolina é um posto e além disso o
sentido sinestésico e vestibular esse da
noção de onde estou pra onde vou eu não
perdi a noção espacial sentido de norte
sul leste e oeste
a posição que você está em são paulo
nas minhas horas vagas eu visitava o
estúdio de gravação algumas estações de
rádio como jovem pan
independe fazer outros cursos fiz
marketing da eletrônica estudei
discotecagem que hoje é considerado
aquele que trabalha com música como dj e
eu
o pioneiro como cego na américa latina a
trabalhar com música
depois disso eu retornei em uberaba e me
fiz seguinte pergunta e aí rapaz
aos 21 anos de idade o que você quer
para sua vida
aí eu quis buscar mais recursos e
informação
eu já tinha uma independência aí eu quis
prestar vestibular
aí então eu prestei vestibular de
administração de empresa no ano de 1978
e continuava discotecando em julho eu
abri minha própria empresa j é don
johnson e eu montei uma equipe que me
ajudava a montar e desmontar ontem um
lema um por todos todos por um tornando
sua equipe forte e unida entrar no
mercado é muito fácil manter nele é o
que é difícil você ter reputação você
ter conceito acompanhar a tecnologia
acompanhar todas as tendências ser
visionário empreendedor
isso é que é importante
sabe por tudo é necessário a gente
vencer todos os obstáculos todos os
desafios tudo aquilo que você pensa que
não é capaz mas aí é a perseverança que
faz com que você supere todos os
obstáculos com toda essa história eu
pergunta você e você quer para a sua
própria vida
muitíssimo obrigado
[Aplausos]